no muy lejos del centro de mi pro hay un
teatro donde los desplazados hacen fila
para comprar algunos productos de
primera necesidad
esta familia oyó de crematorio en el
donbass
necesitamos ropa para la niña porque
está creciendo muy rápido y la ropa se
le está quedando demasiado pequeña no
podemos permitirnos comprarla así que
venimos a buscar algo para ella
algunas veces los desplazados que llevan
un tiempo en micro se convierten en
voluntarios es el caso de iván que sirve
algunas comidas calientes a los recién
llegados
soy un doble refugiado tuve que huir de
donges para ir a jarque
entonces tuve que huir de jarque pero
espero volver
cada tanto creen a este restaurante
sirve unas 100 comidas al día de forma
gratuita a los desplazados internos que
suelen llegar desorientados
no tenemos dinero soy discapacitada
desde chernóbil viví primero chernóbil y
luego dos guerras en el donbass
no puedo volver a casa ya no tengo casa
no puedo reunirme con mi familia están
en la zona ocupada no sé cómo será el
futuro solo quiero la paz para todos
nada más por cien tientas
en mí pero algunas personas están de
paso como esta familia que empacó
rápidamente lo que pudo para oír de la
ciudad de pop croft en el donbass y
llegar al centro del país
y me llevé a toda mi familia a mi gato
[Música]
el gobierno nos recomendó que nos
fuéramos porque no sabemos qué va a
pasar mi madre se quedó allí donde está
el exterior
según el alcalde de la ciudad lo reciba
hasta 15 miles pasados cada día
procedente de jarquín dogmas y mariupol
tanto si deciden quedarse en micro como
si continúan su camino a menudo sienten
que han escapado de lo peor